all right producer nick has a question
for me it's based on an audience
question but he has a a little bit of a
a punch up for it go ahead nick tell me
producer nick um someone in the audience
asked you how your book two is coming up
and i think it's interesting if you
could try and compare and contrast it
with releasing an album you know a lot
of times they say
that
when an artist releases their first
album ever right a musician like jay-z
with reasonable doubt i think he was 27
years old nas with hillmatic he was 19.
all of their
right all of their life's
work to that point is put into that
right and then you know a lot of times
you see the second album is a little bit
of a flop right or a little bit of
less interesting than the first is that
how it works with a book or are you just
so dialed into the process now after
doing the first one that you've learned
from it and you're like this is way
easier and here's where i can improve
upon it yeah so it's a great question
actually and i've been thinking about a
lot um
when i wrote the first book obviously
i'd been a journalist but i'd never
written a large you know 60 70 000 word
book and so i was learning how to
architect a book and um you know luckily
i had harpercollins business that's my
publisher they know how to do that but i
insisted on writing the whole book there
were a lot of people who offered me in
the process hey would you like a
ghostwriter and i was tempted for a
minute like
but i was like you know i'm a writer i
want to do this myself and so looking
back on it the one thing i learned was
i speak like i write and when people
read
uh the book angel which you know it sold
over fifty thousand copies for each
preferred niche book is absolutely
fantastic it's in 11 languages it still
sells great it'll sell hundreds of
thousands of copies over time i'm sure
uh because it's timeless uh but it was
very narrow and focused it was only for
angel investors or people wanting to be
angel investors or four percent of
americans are accredited investors
the next book is for everybody it's for
the world it's literally the topic
everybody's talking about right now it
is big picture it is not narrow it is
the opposite of narrow without talking
or giving away what i'm writing about
and so
i have focused on the process of writing
in the first book i studied my own
writing style and people tell me they
hear my voice when i write when they
read my writing
which is not a coincidence because when
i was learning as a journalist i used to
record myself because somebody told me
hey listen if you're ever got writer's
block just record yourself transcribe it
and then use that as a starting point
and so
when you're a subject matter expert the
words flow easy which i am and in this
new book i'm a subject matter expert
with a lot of experience so it's flowing
very easily in terms of the knowledge
i'm sharing but what i'm working on is
the crafting of the words nick and what
i'm doing is because i just read the
introduction i've read the introduction
to three people
my publisher chamath and my wife
and
the and with jamaat there was a couple
of other people around the table at
dinner
and
they all responded so amazingly to it
when i write now when i was at the beach
in italy writing as you saw on my
instagram i had a technique i would
write
uh jump in the water
i would
listen to it i'd have the computer speak
it to me right highlight it right mouse
click text to speech then i would take
my phone this is my big secret i would
perform the book as if i was doing the
audio book because when i did the audio
book i wanted to change so much about
the pros but it was too late the book
was locked
now i'm thinking about the audio book
first in your experience listening to my
voice because i will do it again
and
when i would go for a walk on the beach
i go walk two three miles i would put my
headphones in and i would listen on
repeat
to myself reading what i wrote that day
or what i wrote the day before
and then i would take notes
i gotta punch this line up there's a
better way to say this so i'm actually
thinking of it more like a one-man show
if you will uh that's something that
doesn't exist anymore uh but if you
think about eric bogosian um you can
look it up uh talk radio he did a bunch
of one-man shows that you know i was
lucky enough to be exposed to when i was
in new york as a kid in a teenager in
the 80s and 90s
i'm looking at it in a bugosian kind of
way of like if i perform this on a stage
if i were to say it
and look somebody in the eye when i say
this line does it actually get you do i
get you on the hook to get to the next
sentence and when i get to that next
sentence when you go to the next
paragraph and i finish that chapter do
you want to like go watch tv or play a
video game or go eat food or you need to
get one more chapter in and i'm thinking
about that so it's really for me about
the pros and the writing the subject
matter is great but it's not an
autobiography but it includes a lot of
autobiography
autobiographical moments so that's my
new thing is i'm writing a book
about a very wide topic but i'm
including
autobiographical moments of mine and my
you know network if you will good answer
i'm also working a lot on sentence
structure so you know there's the
performance of it but then there's also
sentence structure in words and how to
phrase things
yeah
i can't wait for you to read it it's
gonna people are
i think this book is gonna when i talk
to my publisher they're like
you realize the heat this book is gonna
bring on you
and this is the most
i don't wanna say politically incorrect
but
this is going to freak out
certain people
uh in a major way
because it is
i think this book uh has a bit of
categorization right you are
categorizing things yes i am
categorizing things yes i'm building a
framework in the book yes using a lot of
examples yes i don't think that's giving
too much away right okay no
so
in that sense um non-fiction yeah rather
than writing it's it almost seems like
your
the narrative arc of the book is
i'm curious how categorizing things
changes that rather than writing it like
angel where it was
you know how to
linear
yeah you know
what i what i learned from writing angel
and brian alvey helped me a lot with
this is
you know there was a bunch of how to's
but then it feels just like somebody's
pontificating if you don't have examples
and you don't have case studies
i've always found those books like i'm
like well you're just saying words like
where's the proof whenever anybody would
say something to me when i was an editor
of siliconangle reporter or when we were
doing engadget or autoblog when i read
stuff and i saw an opinion i'd say
what's the proof of that give me an
example and it would infuriate writers
because they would say something i'd say
well according to who
who's saying that you're saying that if
you're saying it do you have any
evidence to back it up and so i hold
myself to that standard which is if i'm
going to make a statement i'm going to
say hey this is the way the world is
i want to convince you and you hear me
talking about persuading people when we
do these live streams
and convincing people and explaining
topics to people something i'd like to
really do on the podcast i like to do
one all in and i like to do in my
writing which is if i'm going to take a
position
i really want to
really present the best case and and get
you to buy into what i'm saying or at
least consider it through
real world examples so you know this i
don't want to say too much about it
because we're going to tip too many
cards but i'm i will say this i
i am as excited about this as i've been
about anything in my life you know
professionally so
um i think it's going to be like this
might be like when you look back on my
career like this actually might be the
most important this book might be the
most important thing i do in my career i
actually feel that way right now
like i think this is what i'll be known
for like literally the first line of my
wikipedia page will change to this
that's what i believe
i don't know
that's yeah
but
i think this is on my tombstone author
of beep beep
great question thank you for that
as founders investors and executives we
spend so much time building up the
companies and products that we love and
care about but at the end of the day
life is fragile and it can get taken
away at any moment you know that so it
makes sense why people get life
insurance especially term coverage which
is surprisingly affordable why not pay a
little bit each month to protect the
ones you love it's a no-brainer if
you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it really
fast and easy to get covered you just
need a few minutes and a phone or laptop
to apply ladder smart algorithms work in
real time so you'll find out instantly
if you're approved and that's one of the
great things about the service it's just
so quick and easy to use there are no
hidden fees you cancel any time and
since life insurance costs more as you
age now is the time for you to cross it
off your list and make sure it's there
so go check out ladder today and see if
you're instantly approved you'll find
out very quick go to ladderlife.com
twist again l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
twist that's l-a-d-d-e-r
life.com twist ladderlife.com to see if
you'll get approved do it now